right we're starting off with apologies
we have an apology from councillor
arnold we also have councillor abbott
move that all those in favor
all right
thank you there is
no update of declaration or interest and
there is no public forum and
counselor kit
can i invite you you wish some time to
speak
and
thank you mr chairman
i have made a mistake
and i'm referring to the article
in the southern times on saturday the
25th of september
in the comments i made about air chief
executive officer claire hadley
i should not have been criticizing staff
in the public
arena there are strict rules and
regulations around that
i apologize to claire hadley
claire i am sorry
thank you mr chairman thank you
councillor kit
thanks peter
sorry counselor yeah through chair i
think it's uh
appropriate to acknowledge that the uh
that we've accepted the apology
um
that's not been the
modem of operation in the past that
people haven't apologized with they made
a mistake so
take my head off to me
thank you for your comment
right we're going to move on to
sorry
i've just received a text from
councillor sopa saying she will not be
able to attend
okay happy for that and that is the
motion to be amended
chairman could you mention that we're
going into live streaming
yes i will mention that you worship if
you wish we are now in live streaming
and have been
the wild
riot gonna move it now onto the minutes
of the infrastructural services
committee meeting
held
on zoom in 7th september
can i have someone move that please
thank you
seconded
right i'll put the motion all those in
favor
all aye against carrie
all right the minister minutes of the
extraordinary infrastructure meeting
28 september
happy to move those chair councillor
cricket seconded council amundsen with
emotional lies in favor
hi against carrick that moves us now on
to
the waka kotahi funding
and erin do you wish to speak they're
all
thanks mr chairman
this report really brings um
the funding or the subsidised funding
regime that nzta have
katahi nzta have actually allocated to
council for the next three years
i guess it highlights that there is a
relative tension across all of the
roading
activities across new zealand and that
there isn't sufficient funds
allocated to actually meet the demands
of all the local authorities and as such
that i guess they've had to go through a
process of reallocation
through that process they've done some
national moderation but they've also
issued some interim funding and that
interim funding was quite substantially
less than what we've got
they went through at the end of their
board process and actually reallocated
some extra funding the government had
given so
in an overall sense
the amount of money that we've been
have available for a subsidised program
is more than we've had in the past but
once again our activity management plans
have indicated that we've got ongoing
demands in that area so
part of a guess what
we need to continue to do is to
prioritize those works
and i guess my report highlights a
couple of areas which is obviously in
the footpath area where the amount of
funding that we've requested and the
amount of funding that we've got
has a substantial difference
um during the next three years that's
part of our process will be to actually
look at where the best value for money
we can achieve with the valuable
available funds will be allocated across
our network
and through that process we'll be i
guess reforecasting and focusing on
doing those works that are necessary so
we may wish to change ceiling programs
compared to footpath programs over the
period to actually make sure we do the
right things at the right time but happy
to receive any questions
okay i'm going to open the floor for
questions for russell
since there are no questions
there are three recommendations
um can i have someone move those please
council ludlow second the council
reminds him i'm going to put that motion
all those in favor
[Music]
look i'm just going to
break this at this stage because there
was something i was supposed to say at
the start that i picked up and that is
an apology to pania and evelyn for
missing your names
off the front page here and now that was
purely an administrative oversight
um
that i picked up and thought
and i can assure you it will be there
for the ppp meeting next week
so it's not that we don't love you
just ppp will love you more
[Laughter]
thank you so sorry for that
right going to move on to now temporary
road closures
now
who's going to speak is that russell
thank you russell
thanks mr chairman we've brought this
report being a requirement for us to
have temporary road closures for streets
for
typically for specific events so what we
use is the local government act where it
requires us to consider whether we
unreasonably impede traffic or not
and these are events where we believe
there's community benefit and from that
perspective we don't necessarily need to
go out and have i guess a wider
consultation so we use the alternative
piece of legislation which requires i
guess a much wider
consultation which is 42 days notice and
public notification for event starts
such as um i guess street parties and
you might recall in the past where don
street's had um
functions for the
events
so we have two pieces of legislation and
we've just tried to pull a number of
these together to actually i guess go
through the process of
allowing us to legally be able to have
those roads
closed for those periods and for those
events and mr chairman we i have
identified a small problem with the tour
of southam dates um that's supposed to
at the bottom of the page it's on
appendix one supposed to read the
saturday the 6th of november
because otherwise it was yesterday
okay so those two events so
council adelaide
thanks chief just a question russell was
we normally do street closures around
christmas
races as well have we not
got them in there have they not got
their application
um no they haven't got their application
in but once again that's something that
we would publicly notify because i guess
that's the type of event where you might
have greater community input from that
area
thank you
any further questions for russell
okay the recommendations
uh that we received the report and the
committee
resolves
that the provo proposed events as listed
in the report will not impede traffic
unreasonably
and as permitted under the local
government act
the committee approves the temporary
closure of roads for the events included
and the document attached
can i have someone move that please
thank you councillor crackit secretary
council lewis i'll put that motion all
those in favor
against that is carried
we have the activity report but again
i have slipped up and forgot to advise
you that
there will be a late
verbal update from
general manager of infrastructure and
aaron
at the end
of the activity report so
um erin do you want to proceed with the
activity report
thank you chair um as the activity
reports a joint report between the
infrastructure group and the leisure and
recreation group um i'll pass over to
steve giblin just to provide an update
on the leisure and wreck portion of the
report
thank you erin and
through you mr chair good afternoon
councillors
just a couple of highlights
firstly
queen's park being recently selected of
one of the finalists for the kiwis
choice
keep new zealand beautiful award
um we'll be working with our comms team
over the next month to start getting
information out there about how
our residents can start to vote for
queen's parkers to hopefully try and
pick that award up
i guess the other key factor for this
period of time was the impact that
coveted had on the operations going into
lockdown halfway through the month so
just giving you a flavor of some of the
things that our teams have had to do
both in the park space
which is some core roles that had to
keep working throughout that lockdown
but also
we were tracking incredibly well at the
pool for that period of time to see
probably one of our bigger
months
but unfortunately that got curtailed so
just a couple of some reason happy to
answer any question there
okay
questions for steve
council ludlow
not a question directly chair more a
comment um i guess we were expecting the
uh the flow on from from lockdown to
come through but the communications that
came from the likes of the library and
splash palace
through that process were really useful
even to where they are now
and trying to get people into the habit
of not bringing their books directly
into the library for returns but
dropping them through the hatch and and
with the changes they've had to make at
splash palace on the tale of having to
make the adjustment around um
the water slide that had a monster in it
um
but also coming forward to how pleasing
it was to see that recogni recognition
of the nomination for for queens park so
hopefully
we can get people in behind that i felt
sorry for the staff at the parks staff
who there was one in particular i saw on
a very warm day as i was going for my
elderly amble
who was on a lawn mower masked up and
obviously you don't get too close to
somebody on a lawnmower
and and suffering from the heat while
all these joggers
sprinted through the park without masks
on i didn't feel for them at the moment
but you know they've got health and
safety obligations and they were living
up to them um that aside with the
nomination you know shows why parks are
the dual in their crown
so happy to move that the reports
received you
thank you um
right so that you
that's that part of the report
thank you chair um probably just one
item i'd like to highlight out of the
infrastructure component is that
strengthening works on anderson house
are set to commence in november
um obviously it's been a little bit of a
process for us to get to here but we've
now got all heritage consents resource
consents and building consents in place
and the contractors have confirmed that
um
not regarding covert that they will
still be on track to commence that that
work come november um so that's a key
milestone for us on on that project
um that works expected to be completed
in in april next year
the other thing i just wanted to quickly
verbally note is just that works around
the earthquake strengthening on the
civic theatre
that those works were completed last
week um all signage has now been removed
from that building it is no longer an
earthquake prone building and the 20 000
budget that was allocated for those
works um we're just getting final
invoices in now but um we're expecting
those works to have come in well under
budget
great happy to take any questions
councillor clark um and aaron in
relation to um the alternative water
supply
and i know we're in the early stages of
that but is there any sort of thought
going into whether that
water supply could also um provide
additional water to bluff
and why i asked that as an alternative
to just being a backup for branch zone
because we do have the potential for
green hydrogen down in that area which
is very water intense
and we do have the potential for the
hatchery down in bluff or the king
salmon as well which again is water
dependent so while we're looking for an
alternative supply which might be a
backup for frank's home do we have the
option of
having some capacity down there as well
or is the piping running at capacity now
um look it's something that i've
discussed with the team and that there
would definitely be changes within the
network to do as well
but i think it's something that we'd
have to look at but the first step is
really
what can we get in terms of volume um
and whether or not we have the ability
to do that but definitely something to
explore
yeah i'd hate us to
in some way not to be able to provide to
those two industries
thank you
any further questions
no and we've had it moved and i can't
have a secondary please that will be
received thank you councillor scott i'll
put that motion all those in favor
against carrie
uh aaron would you like to update us
thank you chair
wanted to brief elected members
that we've been doing work around our
stead street stop bank project which is
due to commence next month
we know that as part of the sheet piling
work that will happen along stead street
that we will need to have quite a quite
some significant plant there in terms of
driving those sheet piles um into the
side of the stock bank
when we've worked through the
methodology for that project we've found
that it's not possible to have the plant
actually up on the stock bank itself um
that the the movement and vibration
created by the plant um has the
potential to destabilize the bank and
also destabilize that plant and
equipment so what that means is that we
actually will have to follow a
methodology where the plant will
actually sit down
within one of the lanes on stead street
now the impact that will have is that it
means that during the construction of
that project we are actually going to
have to take stead street down to one
lane
that means that we will only have access
from
invercargill city out to otatara by that
one lane and then we will have to have
the otatara back to invercargill coming
via bay road
that will be for the duration of of that
project from approximately the first
week of november through to april next
year so it's some a project that's going
to have a significant impact on the
community
in terms of deciding which way we would
have the one way going um we definitely
explored the both options we're aware
that the community may have a preference
for the ability to come directly into
town in the morning when people tend to
be in a rush for work
but both from the perspective of
emergency services needing to get
quickly out to otara if needed and also
the ability to control people
from the perspective of if people miss
the signs around one way and we don't
want them to wind up having no option
but to go through the airport to be able
to turn around
we found that the best way to be able to
do that will be via that that one one
weighing on the way out to otara
now in terms of advising the community
the team's been working on an extensive
comms plan for this one over the last
week so there are letters already on
their way that should be arriving today
to the otara community
a media release which will go out after
this meeting
social media and there will also be a
community meeting with otatara towards
the end of october
this project's obviously one that is
about a fifteen and a half million
dollar project of which about two-thirds
are funded by a shovel ready
and i think that anybody who
was in invercargill or has seen photos
of how close that water came up on on
stead street back at the beginning of
last year understands that it's a key
resilience project both for the otatara
community but also for the invercargill
airport as well so a key project but
acknowledging that it is going to have
some impact whilst we move through that
construction phase
i'm happy to take questions
okay questions
people
uh
council allah
uh i guess it's important chair that we
acknowledge that it's going to be
a marked inconvenience
um for the residents of odatara
um
but in listening to aaron's explanation
and
which way is going to be best for having
steed street available for traffic going
to odata rather than traffic coming from
odata invercargill getting those
emergency services out there as soon as
possible if you've got a burning house
or if you've got somebody bleeding on
the side of the road makes makes really
good sense so
thanks for your explanation understand
why it needs to go that way
counselor cricket oh thank you mr chair
just a couple of questions um can you
confirm for me that the cutoff for that
um where it turns to the to one way uh
is
past the airport so you'll still have
two-way traffic to and from the airport
absolutely so that's also part of that
reason for the one weighing is to make
it as simple as possible and provide
that priority to the airport so we will
be retaining that two ways as far as the
airport turn off and then it'll drop
down to the single lane beyond the
airport turn off in the
pedestrianisation
um
and
cycle way will that be two-way
yeah so the current uh cycleway that's
up on the stop bank there'll be a
temporary cycleway there's just enough
width on the side of of stead street
there to be able to have a one and a
half meter temporary cycle way which
will be chip sealed allowing both
directions of travel along that cycle
way for pedestrians and cyclists
will there be any barriers there because
i know that like on on that very right
hand side of steed street it does drop
onto that
ditch
um not on the the ditch side um they're
making sure that there'll be some build
up i guess a lot along that edge to try
to make sure there's no sharp drop-offs
um and there will also be the the lane
delineation between the live traffic
zone um and the cycleway um keeping in
mind though that that one way will still
be subject to
temporary speed restrictions during the
project and when you come round to that
bay road intersection currently gives
priority to all north road travelling
traffic will that be reconfigured or
relooked at so that there will be
priority given to the obvious traffic
flow coming through there now um so not
at this stage but we are looking at just
what we might need to do generally along
bay road to make sure that um it's as
appropriate as possible so that's
something that we'll look at as well
okay
council clark yeah aaron is the mayor of
vadatara um
yeah just like to reiterate everything
you've seen i think it's good um and for
councillor craic there is a current um
margin on the side of the road nearest
the airport that you can pull into if
you've got a broken air vehicle it's
there but it probably will need to be
coned off because
it's still a scary place for some people
that are used to going on the bank yeah
but other than that it's all good
right one of the one of the questions i
had was uh
regarding obviously currents road will
be a feeder onto bay road for those who
choose to
take that access now
at the best of times that's quite a
tricky corner because it's one of those
ones you've got to look
back over your left shoulder and it's
yeah and and of course you've got cars
100k
speed limit down there i'm just
wondering russell i'm gonna point this
one at you
um
safety because the traffic will be
tripling
um
or or even more um
do you see a problem there
because i've seen a couple of
near-misses just
normal times
um thanks mr chairman
i think speed on odata road and current
road will just need to perhaps consider
a temporary speed like an adk in that in
some of those areas just to identify
those areas to make it a little bit
easier but as part of the traffic
management plan needed to set up
and operate the stop bank then they also
will need to make sure that plan takes
the whole travel point
yeah i think it's going to take a lot of
work i think it's going to be a
partnership thing with everyone
you know acknowledging
this is you know just a bit of patience
yeah i think mr chairman one of the
things you'll find is that the people
will actually learn quite quickly about
what how they feel the best routers so
some might use attitude roads i might
use current roads so i think once
they've actually learned a little bit of
that behavior
and how they will travel then we'll see
some better we'll see some better
behavior thank you council clark yeah
again as the mayor of odatara um you're
quite right that corner is terrible
absolutely terrible if you're turning
left coming into town and you turn left
into current road i mean i do the rd run
out there frequently and it is very very
difficult to get around so i think if
we've got uh pressure coming from the
city outwards or pressure on that corner
we should have some warning just before
the corner whether it means we drop the
speed down or whatever it is because
cars do come up and you're very quick
you're quite right to raise the
sharpness of the corner
that's a little knowing how well-versed
the residents of odatara are with the
road code i'm sure there won't be any
issue
it's a difficult corner really yes
um right any further questions for
russell or aaron
no
thank you very much we'll just have to
receive that
okay so
um no further business here i'd like to
uh
again sorry might i suggest that since
there's only the receipt of minutes and
pe that we can rather than moving into
into pe we could just decide to receive
the minutes
i will i will accept that and you will
move i will move that way okay i have a
second of that please
council ludlow
so we are receiving the minutes that are
in the pa section
put that all those in favor all right
against that is carried
and before i close the meeting i would
like to thanks
thank again uh panya and evelyn for
their first meeting
nice short one
you wait till ppp next week she's a
cracker bring a cushion
you're gonna be misbehaving excellent so
right the meeting is now over and we
have a um
workshop and half an hour
you